[Music]
alcohol has been a component of human
culture for thousands of years from its
prehistoric inception to its many uses
in modern times alcohol has had
countless effects on our cultures and
our lines throughout the course of human
history alcoholic beverages have taken
on many forms and flavors around the
world
the earliest known alcoholic beverage
dates back to about 9,000 years ago in
northern China it was a kind of wine
made from fruit honey and rice about a
thousand years later in the Central
Asian country of Georgia the oldest wine
made exclusively from grapes was
produced and around the same time in the
Middle East
the earliest beer was being made from
barley no matter where or what types of
alcoholic beverages are produced they
all share a similar chemistry the type
of alcohol found in beverages such as
beer wine and spirits is called ethyl
alcohol or ethanol ethanol is produced
through fermentation a process in which
microorganisms usually bacteria or a
fungus called yeast cause organic
material to decompose by decomposing
sugars in the organic material are
converted into carbon dioxide and
ethanol the ingredient that makes
alcoholic beverages intoxicating
alcohols intoxicating effects are due to
its role on the human central nervous
system moderate amounts of alcohol
trigger the release of neural chemicals
such as dopamine serotonin and
endorphins in the brain this decreases
anxiety increases happiness and
depresses the brains inhibitory
activities
apart from alcohols mind-altering
effects it has been credited for several
aspects of human culture
[Music]
fermented beverages in ancient China may
have served as a way to communicate with
gods and deceased ancestors at funerary
ceremonies right why similar to those
discovered in prehistoric Georgia is now
a component of the Christian ritual the
Eucharist and in the Middle East the
home of the earliest evidence of beer
the earliest form of writing was also
discovered thought to have developed as
a way to account for the production of
crops including barley for beer through
moderate consumption alcohol may
continue to contribute to countless
other aspects of human culture
you
[Music]